DANIEL PHAM: Hi, my
name is Daniel Pham,
and welcome to This Week in
Android Development on Monday,
December 17, 2013.
Last week, Todd and Wolf hosted
an awesome episode of game
on, showing off the
new open source physics
engine, Liquid Fun.
Today, Nazmul and Laura
Klein talked about Lean UX.
And Todd returned for Lesson
2.0 in his DevBytes series "Play
Games for iOS."
Look for next episode
to drop later this week.
In the latest app news, Google
Santa Tracker has launched--
Yay!-- with three built-in games
and Chromecast integration.
We also heard that you
like managing your devices,
so we gave you the ability
to manage your devices,
from your device, with
Android Device Manager.
Last but not least, the Google
Play Games plug-in for Unity
was launched.
Head on over to Github
for everything you need.
That's all for This Week
in Android development.
We'll be going on
holiday for a few weeks,
so we'll see you next year.
I'm Daniel Pham.
"You are my fire,
the one desire, believe me when
I say-- I want it that way."